today we learned that congresswoman
Acacio Cortez is also facing a serious
challenge in New York's 14th district
because rising GOP star sharee Murray is
an immigrant and entrepreneur she
announced her candidacy today this is
her first interview thank you man for
being with us we appreciate you joining
us thank you it's a pleasure to be with
you this evening Sean you know I just
heard what she said and we have 12 years
it doesn't matter how we're gonna pay
for 12 years left and we shouldn't be
eating hamburgers for breakfast lunch
and dinner I don't know anybody that
does that and the concentration camp etc
comments and everything that you just
heard what is your reaction well it's
disgusting I think the narrative on the
national level needs to be dialed back
and that's why I'm in the race I'd like
to represent the constituents in Queens
and the Bronx and we see AOC from the
time she's been elected she put out
policy like the job-killing green New
Deal
she then went on to kill the Amazon deal
in New York which would have put some
25,000 jobs in Queens and so these are
some of the reasons along with kitchen
table issues that I do believe that a OC
has neglected in her limelight bid to
focus on in the congressional district
there was 25,000 jobs in the district
you're running against her in average
pay 150 Gretna I did think the governor
and the mayor of New York were crazy and
what their giveaways and I think it's
unfair to give benefits to one company
and not another company but that's a
different story
but saying you know do we have to
question having kids they did say the
green New Deal whether you're willing or
unwilling to work basically everything's
for free no more oil or gas in ten years
I don't understand it if we only have 12
years left and that we have to do this
all in 10 years why don't we just party
the next 12 years and it's over anyway
well Sean you have some points there and
I do believe that we have to start
talking about the issues that are
important to the constituents of the
14th congressional district in Queens
and in the Bronx we have infrastructure
that is important to the constituents
our subway system is crumbling our roads
are in desperate need of repair
also Sean our education we need to
really tackle our education system the
diversity here in New York the education
system we really need to start talking
about policy that's going to connect
with the everyday Americans
she mentioned no children right or kids
I'm a mother students how would you
describe yourself politically and and
how do you feel about President Trump in
the two plus years a two and a half
years he's been in office
well I migrated here from Jamaica and I
know firsthand what it is to not just be
an immigrant but to go through the
process right and so what do I think
about what the president is doing I
think that the president is delivering
on his promises when he got elected yeah
well so you are nouns in your candidacy
and we're gonna watch this very closely
I have noticed that a lot of people in
the district of her ISM 25,000 jobs
150,000 dollars on average she let that
go I don't think I was a good shot
listen I just want to get all of your
viewers to go to my website so that they
can learn a little bit more oops sorry
mark
Sheree Murray comm follow me on Twitter
it's been overwhelming the level of
support that I've received so far the
enthusiasm so I just want to say thank
you to all of your viewers and everyone
out there that has just encourages
campaign on our launch today thank you
John
Sheree Murray thank you for being with
us we'll follow your campaign very
closely